Kenisa was asked to pull out
7b ^ 2-5b + 1
of 2b ^ 2 + 3b + 11.
Its solution is shown below and we can see
all the steps she has done.
Asked at what step of the decision Kenisa made a mistake?
It is quite clear that she made a mistake,
because we are not given a variant,
where there is no error.
Let's see what happened here.
The first thing is - we want to get out
7b ^ 2-5b + 1,
we want to get it out
of 2b ^ 2 + 3b + 11.
We see that in step one she did it right.
It really subtracts 7b ^ 2 - 5b + 1
of 2b ^ 2 + 3b + 11 ..
This is without error.
It seems that step one is good.
Now let's see step two.
It seems she wants to reveal the braces after the negative sign,
so the negative of 7b ^ 2 is,
as you can see, minus 7b ^ 2.
We will draw 7b ^ 2.
And then we have the negative to minus 5b.
It will be plus 5b.
So here,
this should be plus 5b here.
Let me do it in another color.
This should be plus 5b.
And then the negative of plus 1
must be minus 1.
That should be minus one there.
Therefore, it made a mistake,
she makes a mistake in step two,
when revealing brackets after this negative sign.
So step 2 is the place to which
the error was actually committed.
From then on it looks right.
It subtracts the coefficients of members with b ^ 2.
So 2b ^ 2 minus 7b ^ 2
gives us that there.
Then, for members with b, you have 3b
and then, let's see ...
It should be 3b plus 5b,
if he had properly uncovered the braces after the negative sign.
But since she did not reveal the braces after the negative sign here,
gets 3b minus 5b.
Here should be 11 minus 1,
but because she did not correctly reveal the braces ...
we have 11 plus 1.
It should be 11 minus 1, as we said before,
because we have to reveal the brackets after this negative sign,
but she left it as a plus
and that's why she got it there.
Therefore, its actual error was in step two.
Because from then on she makes the right calculations,
just made that mistake.